vanadium is going to have a new use I
read about it just a short time ago in
the chemistry journal it said that
bismuth vanadate is a new
environmentally more friendly less
poisonous yellow pigment so I looked up
some recipes and it talked about
controlled pH precipitation of the
compound but we thought we'd just try it
without controlling anything a pigment
is the coloring material you put in
paints and other coatings some of the
best yellow pigments like lead chromate
or cadmium sulfide are very poisonous
now of course people don't necessarily
start eating the wings of their cars and
things like that but on the other hand
it is much better if you can use
pigments that are non-toxic or have very
low toxicity and led chromate in
particular has chromium 6 which is very
poisonous and it has led so it is doubly
cursed bismuth is relatively non-toxic
and so is vanadium so bismuth vanadate
which is in effect a mixed oxide of
bismuth and vanadium is relatively
harmless now I'm not suggesting that you
should eat it but if you had a choice of
eating that or led chromate I know which
one I would choose
I wanted to do a real experiment I got a
student along to come and help me
Erika who's one of my students and her
hand is steadier than mine and of course
when I get excited I shake even more so
we mixed bismuth nitrate and ammonium
metal vanadate and much to our surprise
the first experiment produced a really
nice orange yellow precipitate and it's
really surprising for me as a chemist
you take two solutions that are almost
colorless the bismuth is completely
colorless and the vanadium is just very
pale yellow and suddenly you get this
brilliant color out of nothing so that
was really quite a surprise I got so
excited I went round to the lamp we were
in a teaching lab showing other people
look it's very easy to make pro and i
guess that depending how you make it you
can probably alter the color a bit make
it a bit more orange a bit more yellow
but it's really nice to see simple
chemistry like that suddenly having
important new uses so in a year or twos
time you can probably get bismuth
vanadate on your cars your sauce pans or
whatever thing here we have volume one
of can I call it fill trans yeah you can
we have volume one of fill trans I'm
gonna take the gloves off normally I
wear the white gloves but handling paper
this delicate I'm not going to wear the
gloves you know this is what you are
looking at here is one of the most
magnificent artifacts of all science
what we're looking at here is the
invention of scientific